Conan when I left the Late Night show
we're recording right because this is
gold yeah we won't want to miss this and
this is a a truly painful story when I
left the Conan show
Conan bought me a vintage Rolex that was
like a very specific like a James Bond
Rolex like and oh wait the James Bond
Road yeah yeah yeah that's a that's a
very special watch yeah inscribed on the
back something you know like a nice
message you know like thanks and Conan
and oh no oh no somebody somebody we
were uh changing up uh babysitter house
cleaners yeah and uh somebody swiped it
no from my closet with another with a
box of other I had a couple three other
watches and I put it in a box yeah in my
closet I didn't look at it very often
you know I mean I didn't in fact I
barely ever I wore it only in like super
special occasions yes yes and it was two
months probably before I noticed it was
gone after we fired the religious Maniac
that I think stole oh my God and it had
been two months afterwards
and I just was like how am I how am I
gonna you know wait wait this was
inscribed it was it it had yeah it was
it had it was inscribed and I actually
at times over the years have looked yeah
seen like yeah has anyone ever found a
James Bond Rolex that says two Conan or
two Andy from Conan yeah you know with
the deepest love I'll never forget your
sweet caresses don't don't ever lose
this yeah whatever yeah this watch means
more to you than our relationship more
to me than our race oh my God that well
you know it's inscribed yeah and
um
it's kind of one of it is one of a kind
yeah I so I had anybody out there if you
ever if you ever run across it I'll I
don't know I'll I'll probably give you
what you want for it it may hurt my
children's education but oh gosh I'm so
sorry to hear that you know there is
over because it's been a while it's just
a thing exactly just things exactly and
I and I really do truly believe that and
as I tell the story it hurts there's a
little bit of a
ouch you know yeah especially because
I'm I'm wearing a nice watch yeah I
don't know if we were recording but I I
got a very nice watch from TBS when the
Conan show ended so I'm wearing a nice
watch so in one sense I do I feel like I
have a watch yeah but yeah you know I'm
glad I have this watch and if I lost
this watch I'd be like ooh ouch yeah but
it is it's just stuff it's just stuff I
mean it's a very special stuff yeah once
you lost but you know but they're again
gone forever
but I know I know what time it is it's
1108 yeah
like the time on the James Bond Rolex
it's different it's different it's a
different time yes it is it smells it
smells like vodka
no no I agree with you you know whenever
I lose things and I lose things all the
time and and uh yeah it's that moment of
just panic and depression and then you
it it almost like kind of just puts
things in perspective yeah you know you
just kind of or you have to you have no
choice but to just realize that
it's just the thing yeah I mean you have
had
not much and then had a lot so you know
what it's like to have not much oh and
it's like you don't you didn't have a
lot of fancy stuff no there was probably
more stress or maybe just a different
kind of stress but it's like it's just
stuff what do they say at a certain at a
certain point like like they say money
can bring you happiness at a at a
certain yearly income
level it's not it's not high yeah you
know it's it's like enough to just
survive yeah and and at that point it's
a free-for-all in terms of yeah where
you you know who's going to be happy
who's gonna you know where you're gonna
get your happiness right you know and uh
and whether that money is going to show
like all the flaws in your character
yeah cause boy have I seen that you know
on my path of just like people that make
a ton of money and then it's like oh wow
the real dick comes out you know
so unhappy and it's like you are unhappy
yeah you have so much yeah I I you know
I'm always and I think it comes out
yearly like the happiest countries in
the world yeah and that you know there's
some index and it's always like Denmark
you know it's always like where
everybody's like I don't need to make a
zillion dollars yeah yeah I have a nice
little house and then I even have like a
little house by a lake yeah you know
that's right and I get six months off a
year yeah I don't pay a cent for Health
Care would you would you say you're
happy yes yeah yes yeah at this
particular point in my life I am I'm
very happy
um but I'm also very stressed there's a
lot of stuff going on both personally
and professionally you know
um where it is kind of and also there's
the last few years of my life have
really kind of been like a not knowing
what's going to happen yeah yeah whereas
yeah five years ago if you'd asked me
I'd be like I have a pretty
pretty solid picture of what the rest of
my life is going to be like and that all
got shaken up yeah but mostly for the
best how about you are you happy uh yeah
yeah I think so yeah are you a naturally
happy person or I don't think so oh
really I don't think so yeah I I but I
don't know you know I I think I spent a
good period of my life not happy I think
yeah and uh uh and I think during that
period I don't know it I I just I felt
like a I was just a depressed person
yeah that is my identity you know do you
think it was situational or do you think
that there was I think it was uh yeah I
think it was situational and I think it
was and I think it took work yeah to
yeah it took work therapy therapy yeah
and and just awareness yeah and just you
know uh uh being
more conscious of the moment you know
and and and what's happening right now
as opposed to thinking about
something that hasn't happened yet right
right what you don't have yeah you
should be doing yeah yeah and I I think
ever since I've kind of gotten a good
hold of that I've been I've been way
happier